all it took to put a South Florida
parking lot under water last fall was
the Atlantic oceans high tide
well parts of the nearby Keys stayed
flooded for nearly three straight months
an estimated 150 million people live on
land that will be below with a high tide
line just 30 years from now fighting the
tides can seem hopeless but brook
silva-braga is back from one community
that's come together with a unique
effort Brooke good morning good morning
guys well just look at a map and you'll
see Norfolk Virginia is surrounded by
water the land barely rises above sea
level and the sea level is rising so in
Norfolk flooded streets and front yards
have become a way of life but now after
years of fretting about that flooding a
group of ordinary people has come up
with a novel response the water comes up
from Colley Bay into the street you see
it just flowing right now right into
your yard yep and as the tide rose the
water kept creeping toward John blemings
house which now sits on stilts after I
bought the house I realized it was a
common occurrence after you bought the
after I bought the house how much of a
financial surprise was that about
$90,000 to lift it up low-lying Norfolk
has always faced flooding from
hurricanes like Isabel back in 2003 but
what we saw in John's front yard is
something different when the tide comes
up a little flooding sea water brought
to land by nothing more than a high tide
it could be a sunny day like today
sure and beam lives by the water here
too she told us the house can still get
flood insurance they just had to cut
power to the outlets on the ground floor
I think it's worse than the fall then
she showed us videos of kayakers
paddling down her street in her dog han
Solo floating in space above the same
wall where we were sitting and in a year
that happens how many times oh I would
say maybe 26 26 times yes it's up here
all the time
it's a lot
the US government says globally the sea
level has risen more than three inches
in just the last 25 years and because of
things like erosion and ocean currents
some places have faced more rise than
others Norfolk has evidence of that
thanks to a tidal gauge dating back to
1927 since sewells point gage in the
City of Norfolk was installed there near
the Naval Base it's raised by nearly a
foot and a half Derrick Loftus a
researcher from the Virginia Institute
of Marine Science says that foot and a
half of change comes not just from the
water rising but also because over
development of Norfolk's marshy soil has
been sinking the land we think this will
get worse that we don't really know by
the year 2050 I mean we're kind of
expecting an increase of somewhere
between 0.7 to one foot of water another
foot higher yeah you say that so calmly
you know we've been researching it for
years so I feel like I've known this for
a while but but resignation in Norfolk
may be as common as water in the streets
you can see it's the continuation of a
sidewalk at least that's how it felt to
Dave Mayfield three years ago as he
wrapped up a career as an environmental
journalist for the local paper I was
feeling a bit depressed we're seeing
flooding more and more people are being
inconvenienced and yet nothing happens
yeah nothing happens I wanted to do
something that might make a difference
you know at least in helping engage
people so Mayfield got an idea
he knew each fall the alignment of the
moon earth and Sun cause what's known as
a king tide in otherwise normal high
tide
that's especially strong and more
importantly predictable we would get as
many people as possible out on one day
to measure an unusually high tide have
their data crowdsource into a model
improving flood forecasting he partnered
with a group that had developed a tide
mapping app and dubbed the event catch
the king to his surprise more than 700
people turned out we've got high tide in
thirty minutes guinness-certified it as
the world's largest ever environmental
survey I think what I underestimated was
the innate desire of people to be part
of something larger that might result in
something good there have now been three
annual catch the King events and the
idea has inundated other parts of the
calendar if the tide charts call for
flooding in coastal Virginia you'll
probably find a mapper at the high-water
mark so what we do is we walk along the
water line at high tide and about every
five feet we press a button and that
records our exact location on the GPS
and here's what I've done today that's
the outline of the water yes every place
that I have stopped and and pushed the
app mappers like Bill weary have now
pushed the app tens of thousands of
times yeah I'm gonna take a look at the
data that's coming out of there
their readings end up in the hands of
researchers like Derek Loftus tells us
weather models right or wrong which
scientists live and die by also what's
particularly useful is it helps us find
areas for a potential improvement for
example most the flooding you'll see
today is due to storm drainage systems
and as Mayfield hoped more than anything
it's given ordinary people a way to do
something about a problem no one person
can do much about although we can't stop
the tides eventually some sort of
preventive action is going to be well it
is needed and the more and more data
that the scientists have I think the
better we'll be able to prevent the tide
from causing harm to the neighborhood
may all come out of what we're doing and
usually high tide that we might see on
our annual project day for catch the
king there's going to be a routine high
tide not many decades from now so we
provide I think a window into the future
one offshoot of this project has been
taking water samples when the tide comes
up because and it kind of marinates in
whatever is on the land a professor from
Old Dominion University dr. Margie
Mulholland found that in a single king
tide in entire years worth of runoff
pollution is being deposited into the
left
River that's another big part of it the
pollution lots of lots of concerns and
obviously people there changing the way
they go about their lives having the
park on a side street if they have to go
to work in the morning and I'm glad you
talked about how expensive it is for
folks to raise their homes because these
are massive expenses when you're doing
that hundred two hundred thousand
dollars they're interesting story book
thank you very much
you